>> Greg: WELCOME BACK, SO
DEMOCRAT HOPES GET DOUSED AS THE
G.O.P. CONTROLS THE HOUSE.
THERE WAS NO RED WAY OF A LASS,
BUT WE WILL SETTLE FOR AN
IMPASSE.
BUT WILL THIS BLOW TO HER
MEGALOMANIA MAKE PELOSI RETURNED
TO TRANSYLVANIA?
YES, WE ARE DR. SEUSS AT
FLORIDA.
AT THE G.O.P. HAS FINALLY
CLINCHED CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
THEY HAVE ONE CHAMBER WALL THE
DEMS STILL HAVE A CHAMBER AND
NANCY PELOSI SLEEPS IN WHILE THE
SUN IS OUT.
THEY CONTROL THE HOUSE BY A
MARGIN SLIMMER THEN ME IN A PAIR
OF SKINNY JEANS.
BUT LIKE MY STUTTERING COUSIN
USED TO SAY, WIN IS A WIN.
STILL LIKE ALL GREAT QUESTIONS,
LIKE WHY DO FOOLS FALL IN LOVE?
WHAT HAVE IN ALL OF TUCKER'S BOW
TIES?
WHAT'S UP NEXT FOR THE
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED HOUSE?
THE ONLY THING BOTH PARTIES
AGREE ON IS WAR AND THAT
ADAM SCHIFF IS PROBABLY AN
ALIEN.
SO WILL GRIDLOCK ENSUE?
THE SPLIT CONTROL OF CONGRESS
IT'S AS INEVITABLE AS ME BAILING
KAT OUT OF JAIL TONIGHT.
BUT NO POLICY CHANGES ARE
ACTUALLY A GOOD THING FOR
STOCKS.
BUT ALSO BRACE FOR
INVESTIGATIONS.
KEVIN McCARTHY WHO WILL BE THE
NEW SPEAKER HAS ALREADY
DISCUSSED PLANS TO INVESTIGATE
THE BIG GUY AND PEOPLE IN HIS
INNER CIRCLE INCLUDING HIS SON
HUNTER WHO HAS MORE SHADY DEALS
THAN AN AWNING SALESMAN.
[APPLAUSE]
AN AWNING SALESMAN.
THEY HAVE ALREADY ANNOUNCED AN
INVESTIGATION AS TO WHETHER HE
WAS INVOLVED IN THE OVERSEAS
SHENANIGANS AND WHAT OF
DRACULA'S BRIDE?
WELL, NANCY, SHE ANNOUNCED TODAY
THAT SHE WON'T SEEK A LEADERSHIP
POST.
[APPLAUSE]
SHE WILL ALSO SHOW HER
WILLINGNESS TO COMPROMISE BY
BATHING IN THE BLOOD OF 15
VIRGINS INSTEAD OF HER USUAL 20.
I WONDER WHAT JOE WILL SAY ABOUT
THIS.
>> OH, YEAH, I MISS NANCY, SHE'S
A GOOD GAL, NOBODY COULD RIP UP
A STATE OF THE UNION LIKE HER!
BUT THERE WON'T BE ANY
INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU CAN INVESTIGATE ME, I DON'T
REMEMBER ANYTHING.
YEAH, YOU KNOW, WHEN I SAY DON'T
REMEMBER, I WILL BE TELLING THE
TRUTH!
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE I AM
RIGHT NOW!
ALL I KNOW IS I AM IN A FOREIGN
COUNTRY AND THEY MAKE ME WEAR
JACKETS LIKE THIS.
>> Greg: THAT'S RIGHT, WHAT DO
YOU PREDICT WILL HAPPEN WITH THE
G.O.P. IN CHARGE OF THE HOUSE?
>> Tucker: I LOVE YOUR
STUTTERING COUSIN, A WIN IS A
WIN.
WHO WRITES THAT?
>> Greg: I WROTE THAT.
THINGS THAT MAKE ME GRIMACE.
A >> Tucker: IF I JUST WROTE
THAT, I WOULD RETIRE.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT MY STUTTERING
COUSIN WOULD SAY.
>> Tucker: DO YOU HAVE ONE?
>> Greg: NO, NOTHING I SAY IS
TRUE.
>> Tucker: I KNOW THAT, THAT'S
WHY I LIKE IT.
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE SOME
INTERNAL DRAMA TO SETTLE, THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, SO LIKE WHAT
DOES THE REPUBLICAN PARTY STAND
FOR?
WE KNOW WHAT IT STANDS AGAINST,
THE CURRENT INSANITY TO THE
NATION OF THE COUNTRY, SO MANY
THINGS, BUT WHAT IS IT FOR?
THAT IS NOT A SETTLED QUESTION
AND I THINK IT WILL BE WHEN A
NOMINEE IS CHOSEN AND THAT
PERSON WILL RUN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S A JUMP
BALL AND THERE IS A LOT GOING ON
WITH THE SPEAKER'S RACE AND
KEVIN McCARTHY, SO IT IS VERY
HARD TO PREDICT, BUT I THINK I
KNOW WHAT THE FIRST BATTLE WILL
BE, I DON'T KNOW HOW IT WILL
WIND UP BUT OVER UKRAINE, AND
NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THIS
CRYPTO EXCHANGE WAS ACTUALLY
LIKE THE FINANCE ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOVERNMENT
OF UKRAINE, I THINK IT'S A LOT
MORE COMPLICATED AND THAT
BECOMES A REAL DEBATE VERY SOON.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, KAT, TUCKER
SAID YOUR FAVORITE WORD,
FUNDING.
WE WILL DO A LOT OF SEGMENTS ON
REMEMBER HOW FUN THAT WAS ON
"THE FIVE" NOTHING BETTER THAN
AN A BLOCK ON FUNDING, BUT YOU
ARE A LIBERTARIAN, YOU HATE
FUNDING.
>> Kat: NO, I JUST LIKE TO
KEEP MY OWN FUNDING.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
I WOULD ACTUALLY LOVE FUNDING
ME, AND I DON'T NEED YOU TO FUND
ME, JUST LET ME FUND MYSELF.
>> Greg: YOU ARE TOTALLY INTO
FUNDING YOURSELF.
>> Kat: YEAH!
LOOK AT, COMING OUT OF THE GATE
AND BEING LIKE WE INVESTIGATE
HUNTER, I GET WHERE THAT COMES
FROM, BUT MOST PEOPLE ARE LIKE
OKAY, CAN WE FIGURE OUT WHY
CHEESE COSTS $47?
CAN WE DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT?
GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE, IT'S
LIKE IF -- IT'S LIKE WALKING
AROUND AND GETTING SLAPPED IN
THE FACE OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
YOU SEE HOW MUCH THINGS --
AND THAT, I AM DISGUSTING, I AM
GREG, WE GET IT.
BECAUSE I GET WHERE THEY WILL
WANT TO DO IT, BUT THEY HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING ELSE AND STAND FOR
SOMETHING RATHER THAN OKAY,
PEOPLE WENT AFTER TRUMP, SO WE
WILL GO AFTER THIS GAIA,
ESPECIALLY WHEN SO MANY PEOPLE
ARE STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: TYRUS, I DISAGREE
WITH KAT, I WANT TO HUNTER BIDEN
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THERE ARE
SO MANY BELLS AND WHISTLES AND
MAN, THE RATINGS FOR THE SHOW
ARE GOING TO BE AMAZING.
>> Tyrus: THE RATINGS ARE
FINE, AND OF COURSE YOU JUST
WANT TO TALK ABOUT PROSTITUTES
AND WEIRD STUFF.
THAT'S WHY.
BUT IF YOU LIKE SOMETIMES, YOU
KNOW, YOU ALWAYS OFTEN, I WAS
WONDERING HOW DOES WRESTLING
EQUATE TO POLITICS?
SUCH A DIFFERENT THING, BUT THEN
IT IS LIKE IN WRESTLING, WE KNOW
HOW TO BUILD THE CARD AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT THE HOUSE
NEEDS TO PAY ATTENTION, CHILDREN
IS YOU DON'T HAVE THE BIGGEST
MATCH FIRST.
IF YOU BUILD, OKAY.
SO THE FIRST THING IS HOW ABOUT
DEALING WITH THAT LEAP AT THE
BORDER WITH THOSE OFFICERS WHOSE
LIVES WERE CHANGED, WHO WERE
ACCUSED OF RACIST WHIPPING
PEOPLE AND --
YOU WANT TO IMPEACH SOMEBODY,
GET ON THAT!
SECOND PLEASE DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE IRS!
THOSE TWO THINGS, WHETHER YOU
ARE A DEMOCRAT, INDEPENDENT,
MODERATE, REPUBLICAN YOU WILL BE
LIKE THOSE THINGS ARE GOOD
THINGS, BECAUSE IF WE HAVE NOT
LEARNED ANYTHING IN THESE LAST
TWO ELECTIONS IT IS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS OUTNUMBERED.
THERE ARE MORE DEMOCRATS THAN
THERE ARE REPUBLICANS, AND WE
SEE THAT, SO WHAT DO WE HAVE TO
DO?
WE HAVE TO BUILD BRIDGES.
YOU SAVE HUNTER BIDEN UNTIL I
DON'T KNOW, SIX MONTHS BEFORE
THE NEXT ELECTION, WHEN THAT
STUFF COMES OUT AND HE IS
RUNNING AGAIN, YOU WILL BE LIKE,
LOOK AT ALL OF THIS DIRT.
AND WE LOOK AT ALL OF THE STUFF
THEY DID AND THEY ARE BRINGING
HIM TO JUSTICE, THAT'S HOW YOU
BUILD BRIDGES AND THAT'S HOW YOU
WIN COLLECTIONS.
STOP -- HUNTER IS GREAT, BUT FIX
THE STUFF AND PLEASE, THE MEN
AND WOMEN ON THE BORDER WHO HAVE
BEEN TREATED LIKE CRIMINALS WHO
RISK THEIR LIVES EVERY DAY, THEY
DESERVE THE ATTENTION OF THE
HOUSE FIRST.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT!
SO I THINK WHAT TYRUS IS SAYING,
DANA, IS THE BORDER, IRS, THEN
WE GET THE HOOKERS.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHEN WE GET
THEM?
I WILL PUT IT IN MY CALENDAR.
THEY HAVE A LOT TO DEAL WITH IN
TERMS OF THE FACT THAT THE
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO HAVE THE
DASH REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA SAID I
HAVE A PEN AND A PHONE, THAT WAS
AFTER HE LOST THE MAJORITY, WHAT
DOES HE DO?
LEGISLATION WENT DOWN BUT
REGULATIONS WENT WAY, WAY UP.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THEIR OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES AND
CAN CHECK IN.
WHERE IS BASICALLY THE
HOMELAND -- NOT HOMELAND, BUT
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY, HE
NEEDS IT, BUT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SECRETARY IS IN THE WITNESS
PROTECTION PROGRAM, WHERE IS HE
BEEN?
WE HAVE A LOT OF TALKING ABOUT
WITH THE ORIGINS OF COVID,
SOMEDAY CAN HAVE SOME ACCOUNT
ABILITY ON THAT FRONT.
ON NANCY PELOSI I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING THAT SHE WOULD NOT
HAVE JUST DECIDED TODAY TO LEAVE
CONGRESS ALTOGETHER.
INSTEAD SHE IS JUST QUIET
QUITTING, SUCH AS NOT TO BE LIKE
ACTUALLY, I'M NOT GOING TO BE IN
LEADERSHIP ANYMORE, I'M JUST
GOING TO SEND IN THE BACK.
AND HOW IS THE NEW GUY SUPPOSED
TO FEEL LIKE AN POWERED WHEN SHE
IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE LOOKING
OVER HIS SHOULDER?
>> Greg: THE GHOST OF TH